[Music]
cool so welcome again to developing made
easy nothing to do with microphone or
presentations though so yeah we'll talk
about ultimately tools libraries I would
try to make your life you know easier as
a developer and make the developing
experience simpler for you guys so
whether you're new to GCP or you've used
it for a while we think that everybody
here has a thing or two actually to
learn from from the stock so you can you
know again be more productive so we can
just get started right ahead but before
some quick introductions quick
introductions my name is Lamar Ayub I'm
a product manager in Google cloud and I
focus on the developer experience and
specifically on client libraries and I'm
from Seattle Washington and I love to
travel international affairs and have
the pleasure today of being joined with
Eileen yeah
my name is this one hi everyone my name
is Eileen Althea I'm also product
manager in Google cloud platform
focusing on cloud SDK I live in New York
City and on a personal note I love
sailing as well as generally that's the
supplies you wanted great so that's what
we both travel here today to talk to you
about developer experience so
specifically what you can expect from
today's talk is I will take you on a
whirlwind tour of developer tools so we
have a lot of them we won't touch on
everything but we're really going to
focus on three mainly the cloud shell
we'll talk about some of the workflows
that that enables as well for you we'll
talk about the cloud SDK and Eileen is
going to walk us through that it's a set
of tools and libraries we have in cloud
and then we will talk about the cloud
client libraries which are there to
basically allow you to have programmatic
access to our API s so Before we jump
into every artifact just a quick visual
about where the developer tools fall
within the context of GCP so we have the
tools at the bottom here and the ideas
that they allow you to access the GCP
services as you would expect and we have
a lot of services this is just a sample
you know the hexagon show you specific
server
and the purpose here the idea is to make
it simple and easy and no depending on
what you're trying to achieve
you notice that we've separated the
services into two buckets this is not
hard thing is just for the purposes of
this talk
it helps visualize on the one side we
have the platforms so by platform you
mean things where you want to run your
code right it's only one hand we have
App Engine this is our platform as a
service offering which allows you
ultimately to run your code and not
worry about anything else so you write
your code you deploy it and then you're
up and running now the thing is we have
two flavors of App Engine and I just
mentioned that because we will be
referring to this during the talk we
have App Engine standard which is a
sandbox environment we have App Engine
flex which is based on containers if
you've used UCP before you're familiar
this is all I mean known to you but just
to be sure around the same page and then
we have container engine this is
basically a cluster manager for your
docker containers so you specify your
docker containers and then we scale up
we scale down for you as a managed
service now one of the cool developer
tools here in workflow that we have that
we won't touch on today but I encourage
you to look into is you can use
container builder which just went
generally available very recently you
can use that to build your container
images which then will get saved to
container registry also in the cloud
it's a registry for your docker
container images and then you can run
this on container engine as a nice
workflow from end to end so I encourage
you to go look into that for container
builder and finally we also have compute
engine this is basically our
infrastructure as a service offering so
you want a VM we'll give you a VM and
you have more flow you have full control
basically which one to install and
whatnot so again the idea here is that
developer tools allow you to manage
these resources to push code on it and
you can see how CLI Zoar command-line
interfaces might be the good solution
for this part then on the other side we
have our API right we have translations
storage big query ultimately you want to
get data when your application is
running you want to save in a table you
want to analyze a piece of text using
the cloud natural language API all of
that you would use obviously you know
programmatic access and client libraries
is where you'll probably want to go in
and be able to do this and of course the
application running using these api's
could be running on one of the platform
oh it could be running locally or
running on some another platform great
given that context we can now start and
talk about our different artifacts so
quick story actually I came to SF like
two days ago I flew down from Seattle so
I'm in the airplane in the and in the
aisle doing my work right so I have my
laptop it has all my developer tools on
it I've been using it for a year and a
half so I have all my languages on my
GCP tools I'm doing my work and then out
of nowhere and this is true story by the
way on my left hand a certain noticing
some coke appearing then on my hand then
on my laptop and like all over my laptop
and I look up and the actual flight
attendant by mistake just like drop
everything on my laptop I was wonder if
that actually happened if that but
actually it does so heads up this might
happen to you so I get back to SS I'm
like great obviously my did is all
backed up but I'm like I have to get a
new machine reinstall everything and for
me to be even productive minimally you
have to do all of that and I my first
fly was like if only I could log on
somewhere and have everything
pre-installed and I can just like hook
up my data and I'll be up and running
and it's kind of a wishful thinking but
then I realize this is exactly what
cloud shell does so in reality cloud
shell no kidding is a command-line
interface where you log on in the cloud
and you literally get access to a bunch
of GCP tools and you can start being
productive right away so by the way this
was not a setup story like this actually
happened I just click in my mind this is
amazing this is like a perfect perfect
like timing for this so literally what
actually happens is you only need a
browser you log on nothing to install
locally and right there you have a bunch
of tools pre-installed and by tool them
you like text editors so you have Emacs
vim you have Nano you have gets
pre-installed the cloud SDK which is a
bunch of C lies and Ilene will talk
about that a little bit later but
everything is pre-installed up-to-date
you have nothing to do and we support
seven languages out of the box so we
have Java Gomez no HP Python Ruby the
interpreters the compilers the package
managers you can do pip install it's all
there and the beauty is that it has
built-in authorization so no need to log
on again you can just execute and just
work
I could give you guys more and more
features but probably easier if I just
show you how it works in the console so
we'll switch to demo lovely so what
we're looking at right now is literally
the main landing page when you log onto
GCP if you've done this before this is
not new to you you're looking at
projects and every cloud resource you
create will be within a project so to
manage these resources if you go to the
top left corner you click on that you'll
see a menu with basically a bunch of so
if you click on that you will see a menu
with a bunch of the services some of
which we talked about earlier App Engine
compute engine container engine anyways
the point being is that you can use that
to do your management through the UI but
like we talked what if you want to run
some automation you want to write some
code you want to well we probably need a
shell for that so if you go to the top
right corner you'll notice there's an
activate cloud shell you click on that
and that will start the cloud shell so
what happens in the background this will
let you know that a virtual machine a
small one gets created and it has all
the tools screens all right there and
what it does is it mounts five gigabytes
of storage that you own so every person
here when you log on with your Google
account gets five gig of persistent disk
storage for free and that gets mounted
as your home directory in the cloud
shell because it's mounted on the VM so
if you do a PWD for example you would
see that we're in the home directory of
where we are and everything is saving
that will get persisted so if you log
off you come back in a week everything
you say will be there so you can see how
you can start writing scripts writing
automation writing some code everything
will be saved and also just to show you
if we do get get - - version you'll see
that we have you know that install as
well now we talked about in talk about
Emacs that was a big war between the two
which one's better we have a solution
which is basically to go in the top left
corner you'll see her files and if you
click on launching the code editor this
is experimental right now but this is
basically a UI for you to be able code
to do coding directly in the browser so
if you're more into that and using a
user interface this is what you can do
and notice here that what we're looking
at is your home directory also mounted
so whatever you save in there will get
persisted again just like earlier it's
the same view
all right so we talked about you know
having the tools we talked about having
a code editor everything is pre setup we
have five gigabytes of space so in the
next part we'll just really create a
very small web app and Python just to
show you what can actually be done and
it will walk through some of the
workflows so you can get a better idea
of what's enabled directly from the
console again without installing
anything locally so let's go ahead and
do that so we'll create a new app we'll
call it you know my app and that will be
a Python web app so exactly very simple
so the first thing we'll do we'll create
a main doll pie and that will contain
remain our main code now we could go
ahead and do that but if you're familiar
with App Engine standard we do have the
QuickStart in there that explains
exactly how to get started and this is
actually we're going to go and copy that
code again the goal is to make it very
simple just to show you the other tool
that we have around that so in this case
you see that we have a very simple web
application we'll copy that in and what
it does is imports web app 2 which is a
App Engine standard web framework then
we register a get handler well we just
you know print out hello world we could
change that to hello next for instance
and then we're going to register the app
for the handler ami so that is done
we're done that is as simple as possible
web app you can join Python but given
that we want to run this on App Engine
standard and you'll see that in a second
we're going to have to create an
abdominal file so we'll just create this
new file this is very typical just the
way of selling app engine by the way
your platform as-a-service but you still
need to know what type of application I
am so going back to the quick start if
you want to go and look at encourage you
to take a look at it very simple and you
see that we register or simply select L
app engine this Python and we tell that
so what handlers we have registered
that's it we're done so we can go back
to the cloud shell we've literally built
an app so if we do an LS you see that we
have a my app folder saving our five
gigabyte of persistent storage we can
log into that or CD to that and then at
this point something else that's
installed pre-installed for you is the
tooling for App Engine standard so one
of which being dev appserver so this is
just a tool allowing you to do local
testing so dev appserver
we pass in the ABS I am Oh hit enter and
this basically will start on the VM
locally the actual web app
now do notice that it's listening on
port 8080 but if we went on the browser
now in port 8080 would be connecting to
this machine right we want to connect to
the VM well in the top left corner of
the cloud shell you'll notice there's a
button where you can click and you have
a web preview and that allows you to
connect to port 8080 only to your
account on that machine and you see that
very seamlessly it just worked we can
have hello next we can do obviously you
can make this much more complicated this
is just to get things going quickly
alright so we have this imagine we love
this app exactly what we wanted and now
we want to deploy to App Engine standard
right we want to make it live so for
that we can just kill the application
here the testing and go ahead and do a
g-cloud app deploy now we talked about G
clouds a little bit because it's part of
the cloud SDK but Ilene will give more
details a little bit later so G cloud is
basically a command line interface that
allows you to interact with the cloud
services in this case app means app
engine so it allows you to interact with
the App Engine service deploy to deploy
app we pass in abdominal and it will
just do dash dash version two this is
not mandatory but you'll see later we
want to know the version and version
just made up something so we can hit
enter
lovely so this will run the background
now one thing we forgot to do by the way
we should probably do that right now is
version control best practice let's do
this well notice it's a plus button
right next up here we can create a new
shell session so you click on that we
start a new session and now we can run
the git commands right so we do a CD
into my app and then we'll just do you
know the typical get dance like get in
it get at star and then we'll just do a
get yeah get initial commit a git commit
dash M yeah perfect initial commit great
so just to show you that you can do a
ously a local repo because the five
gigabytes will get persisted however
what if you want to collaborate with
other people right like software
engineering you're actually building an
app you want to share with others you
probably use github or bitbucket and I
like to use big buckets or my private
projects but in this case perhaps
something you didn't know about is that
we do have private gates repositories in
Google cloud platform and it's called
the cloud source repositories so in a
new tab if you click on it you go into
menu you go
lower down you'll find under tulle
something called development if you
click on that this is literally a fully
featured private get repo so we can
create a new repo will tell it staged
repo and that is ultimately a remote
repository now just to let you know as
an FYI if you wanted to you could still
have stuff in bitbucket or github and it
automatically sync back to this repo by
the way so you can keep both in Singh
and their advantages to that as we'll
see later especially when you use App
Engine but for now we'll do the typical
workflow right we have our local
repository and we're going to push
everything to this remote repository so
if we click on I guess repository on the
Left we can just copy paste the remote
URL go back to cloud shell and get
remote add call it Google and pass in
the URL and then we'll just do a git
push Google master right and just for
completeness once this finishes we'll
head back to the repo and show you how
you know all the files have been
ultimately like I've been pushed
beautiful and you have everything you
would expect here where you would have
like commit history you have branches
you can have tags everything's there do
disks between files it's all up in here
okay how we doing on App Engine Center
did it deploy let's see it did awesome
so this is basically now the live URL
and now it took a couple of minutes not
even Ashley because we're switching and
whatever we wrote is now live on App
Engine standards so quick recap here
right we have the cloud shell bunch of
tools our install you can start coding
start developing you have the code
editor to do that then we do a bunch of
get we push to the source repository
we're able to test locally we will to
push to App Engine standard the last
thing I'm going to do in this workflow
is debug it so we'll go back to a tab
and maybe you're not aware of this it's
probably one of my favorite features by
the way in products you go to sack
driver debug now what we're looking at
here is literally a debugger in the
cloud so we're connected to GCP right if
you notice here there's a
then this is default - to remember when
we specify the version - this is where
it shows up
it's called default because we're in
specify a name to our App Engine
application but if you wanted to the
name would show up here
it picks up the App Engine running and
on the left hand side you see the files
because we use cloud source repository
it can pick up the files there as well
and do the connection between the App
Engine running the code right and the
files checked in and the source repo so
now we're looking at actually at the
code that we wrote we copy/paste it and
now we're going to put a snapshot point
as you know some line do realize that
identity a break point because we're not
breaking the app what's going to happen
here is that we're telling App Engine
hey please when you see the code or the
application executing this code ask tick
snapshot take a snapshot of the call
stack take a snapshot of the local
variables send it back to me so if we
open the live URL that we have for App
Engine hit a refresh it will execute the
get write we go back snapshot was hit if
you look in the lower right corner
you'll see the call stack you'll see the
local variables everything you need and
this would be clear we didn't stop the
app app is still running we have to
create another version to put lock
statements this is live happening
directly and if you wanted to you could
also put a conditional snapshot point so
yeah so that was basically the full
end-to-end workflow we can switch back
to the slides now
so quick recap I just said it but really
quickly like the stuff you might want
look into a bit more the cloud shell
comes with the code editor in
experimental but it'll get there it
would obviously move to beta and
everything else we have App Engine we
have source repositories and we have the
secretary debug and all of that without
logging on with only logging on without
installing anything locally as simple as
we can make it now if you think this is
really neat but is there more the answer
is yes there is cloud shell Pro so right
now actually at next we have an alpha
version open only to next attendees so
you can have a bigger VM more CPU write
more RAM so if you interested I highly
suggest going to this bitly link shell
bash Pro it's a small form you can fill
it out and we'll reach out to you and
please you can give us feedback
don't know what you like let us know
what's missing you know maybe more tools
whatever we want to hear from you great
that being said now we can jump to the
next part which is the cloud SDK and
Eileen will explain that to us thanks
Omar it was really cool to see all those
actions you can do it in browser with no
installation but what is if you have a
use case to access all these services
between your local machine van cloud SDK
is your solution
it contains a bunch of command line
tools but lets you access the Google
cloud services for example beat you to
access peak Larry gsutil
access storage and G cloud which is the
primary command-line tool that lets you
access multiple services like App Engine
compute engine data product machine
learning API and many more indeed I will
focus on G cloud for my rest of the demo
but I'll also also show you the
components that you get when you install
cloud SDK configuration and installation
is super easy you can get it on Linux
Mac or Windows actually with no further
slides I will go ahead and jump into
demo mode so we can see cloud SDK in
action awesome
so I'll just search the first thing we
have to do is to install it so I'll just
search Cloud SDK installed and we will
go ahead the installation documentation
here and you will see that a couple
options that you can get it through zip
file or you can get it interactively by
running the car command so if you
haven't done so I highly recommend you
start your installation
I already installed it prior to demo so
I'm not going to do that but let's start
together the next step you have to do
after installation is initializing cloud
SDK so in order to do that we are going
to run g-cloud init commands so let me
go back to my terminal and let some
g-cloud init so this comma what this
command will do is that it's gonna
create a new configuration or if you
have already existed
existed configuration you can also
switch in here but I created one
configuration before but let's start
anyone together so this will let us this
command will let us set up our project
our SDK so we can talk to cloud services
online so first thing we have to do is
to give a name the configuration you can
create multiple and switch with me and
it's going to ask us the username you
want to connect the services so I
already can't use multiple usernames
before but let's go ahead and start with
a new account so this is going to open a
browser and let us to choose account so
this is the demo account we created
before then Cloud SDK ask for certain
permissions to access services let's
allow it and boom we are authenticated
to Cloud SDK if the go back to our
terminal now you'll notice that we are
getting all the projects that was
created under this account before so I
created a project before in the UI
console next demo g-cloud so we will use
it for the rest of the demo and the last
question is if you want to say if you
want to set the compute engine settings
this is going to make it across the zone
so I'll go ahead and set this on so we
don't get prompted for the zone in the
future but you can always set the wrong
flag or change it in the future so I'll
just go ahead and select us tantalum a
key test and awesome we are all set and
ready to talk to services now let me
clear it okay remember I mentioned to
you cloud SDK contains bunch of command
line tools let's go ahead and verify
which components you get after you
install so when I run g-cloud components
this command these are all the
components we see some of them are
installed by default like DQ g hcto big
lot and there are multiple more that is
nothing stalled by default but if you
have use case you can always go ahead
and run g-cloud
component update commands and for
example keep CTL
you if you have a use case Noctis
kubernetes PLA you can go ahead and run
this command to update and install those
components
so I'm not going to do that we are not
going to focus on that but you get the
idea and notice that there are two also
g-cloud a specific comment on the data
and alpha I install this prior to demo
these are not installed by default but I
will show you a very cool feature today
on the alpha command which is our
experimental command group that we are
currently working on which is available
to public as long as you install this
command group so I recommend you to get
your cloud component updates to alpha
and you notice here you see also the
version if your version is pointing to
old one you can always verify here our
team is launching versions often so I'd
recommend you to check and get the
latest perfect now we install the SDK we
initialize it we check the components
and we get the ones that we are going to
use now what is next so we have to know
which command to run right and I assume
some of you may not know how to run
g-cloud command so there are two ways
you can figure out which commands to run
the first thing could be g-cloud head
you can run it and this is going to
bring you basically the manual page the
reference page to see the selected
available the commands that is available
you can see like the app that we use
default access App Engine compute engine
container and so on or you could do the
same thing by going to our reference
page here and you see exactly the same
information if you prefer to see it in
browser but here is the problem if you
are trying to basically come up with the
command that you never used before or if
you are trying to discover new services
so this context switching between the
manual page come back and continue
typing may be inefficient and
time-consuming
in order to solve this problem we have
been working on a feature called
G cloud interactive shell which lets you
get auto prompting of the command and
the flag as you type with inline
documentation so you don't need to do
this context switching okay let me show
it so you get the idea remember I
mentioned you that I have something cool
to show you on the offer comments this
is it and we are just announcing
today so g-cloud official if you run it
this is going to bring up the shallows
you can see your configuration at the
bottom here that we authenticated our
username you see the project that we
picked up and now you can start using it
so we don't know how to use it how about
we create a compute instance together so
I just start by typing C and it gives me
a prompting of the command and I can go
through them and in here I see the
description of thoughts and I see the
syntax how to use it and if this
information is not enough since there is
a limited space you can always control
double use to open the full browser so
before going to complete user journey
remember all my mentioned earlier that
container builds event - generally
available recently what if you want to
learn how to use that command so we will
type container let space let's hit space
and this gets us all the commands
available on the container service so we
can go through ok builds is the one that
we wanna learn and we hit space and we
get through to all the groups command
groups under that and submit is the one
that lets you run your local docker file
and move it to a container registry
Danny can deploy it to your container
engine after it's really cool that we
had no idea how to run this command
before but we can discover basically the
services this way and when you look at
the syntax the next thing for us put the
source here the docker file source or -
- config or the take flag and he's done
this should work fine but if you want to
see more like I mentioned control W
would go to the reference page online
and you can go through the everything
here and understand and read multi want
them so let's go back today I'm not
going to focus on containers we had an
intention to create compute before right
so let's go back to our original example
compute let's go to instances and we
will create but you see all the
available commands here
let's hit create and perfect I see the
syntax here the next thing I need to
view a name let's give a name stage
VM and this is a this should work right
I done it so this is going to take
couple of seconds to create the VM but
you get the idea you had no idea how to
run the complete command or a container
command we discovered it we solve the
usage and basically we created a compute
instance without that without hitting
any errors and successfully ran the
command here so with this oh just on
time it just created the instance so I
will exit from the this shell mod and
we'll show you more advanced feature now
we know how to run command but most of
you probably want to take this and
automate these workflows with your
scripts right so in order to do that I
will show you some advanced features and
power your scripts so let's run the
command that will list out all the
instances we created including the one
that we just created see in here stage
VM is the one we just created running
and prior to our demo I created some
instances I terminated some of them just
to give you a feeling of how it looks
like so now when you run this command
you get human readable summary but in
your scripts you prefer to get a format
that is computer readable right so we
support formats like Yemma
json csv and more so if we're on the
same command by pressing the format flag
equals to json we would get exactly say
exchange without button json with more
fields available for your scripting let
me clear now and let me run the same
command instances list okay
how about next step maybe you are only
interested in the vm that is currently
running so you can go ahead and
programmatically filter out the one that
is running but you don't need to we also
have a comment for you that is - -
filters when we do that we can specify
any field equals any value so we can get
the filter by the value we wish to so we
wanted status
equal to running light let's run it and
perfect this game adjusted running one
so you don't need a programmatic to do
that and I also want to mention that you
can mix and match the filter and format
remember earlier we did the format for
JSON we could also get specific values
that we don't need maybe we are only
interested in getting the name of the VM
so we would say value name run it
perfect we get just the values of the
names and at the next step what we could
do take this command and put it to maybe
G maybe to compute instances delete as
an input so you want to delete after you
are done so you just touch the name to
another command so you can pipe the
output to it as an input another comment
that you can create it's more
sophisticated workflows this way so with
this we also have more functionalities
that is built-in for you like sorting
you can label and you can do some
formatting for Day dates and things and
many more so I encourage you to go
through the our documentation and see
other features that could empower your
steps with this I am done with my demo
let's go back to our slide perfect so
today we took the journey of installing
cloud SDK and we initialized it to be
able to talk to services we picked our
user name we get the project we said
some computes on by default we created
the configuration right and then we
moved on to see some components we went
through the component of dqg it will
resolve also command basic commands and
specifically for an alpha comments today
we saw an interactive shell that lets
you get auto prompting or of flags and
commands so you don't need to contact
switch as you are typing this is a
perfect tool for you to discover new
commands or discover the usages then we
took the journey of discovering a
container builder and then we moved and
we created a computer VM together then
we moved to create more to see some more
advanced features like filtering
formatting and just to give you idea to
empower your scripts and automate these
workflows so it's a next step I really
highly encourage you to install SDK
please get the Alpha components try to
run g-cloud alpha shell and please give
us feedback by running G class feedback
comments awesome thank you so much with
that I will give it to Omar to cover
client libraries next thanks Eileen
great
so it works often so client library is
that so we looked at how to use the
cloud shell how to run commands and
tools how to use the cloud SDK again
everything in the shell right using a
CLI now we're going to talk more about
programmatic access to our API s so we
have cloud API s we have many of them
35-plus right and what is an API
ultimately is an interface you get a
version it expects parameters the
request body and you get a response you
have to parse it now of course you could
go and use the endpoint directly and
literally code against the endpoint into
all of that offs and requests and
response parsing yourself but clearly to
talk about making things easier so that
would not be fun for anyone not fun to
get started and also not fun to just
keep going right so ultimately you want
to have client libraries that allow you
to connect with these services and a fun
idiomatic way so in cloud like I said we
have about 30 plus if you have 35 plus
about a third of those are now using the
new Google Cloud client libraries so we
haven't covered all of them yet we're
working on that but a good you know a
good third of them all ready for you to
go and play with and have fun with and
the whole idea is to make these
libraries more usable a simple interface
idiomatic and more importantly
well-documented because you can have the
best library in the world if you don't
have samples to get started and good
examples to keep going and more
tutorials for or how-to guides you'll
probably you know at some point rated
and heads up we actually support seven
languages here as well again go java.net
PHP Python no Ruby and everything is
open source on github so again we'll
just jump directly to showing you how to
use basically this programmatically
so lists should never mind we switch
back to the demo so actually we're gonna
work walk through a user journey very
simple one so you've probably heard
about obviously the machine learning API
is it's a big deal rightfully so and
probably the vision API so imagine
you're curious about it you want to make
use of it how can I call it so first
thing you probably do is just search for
it right so what walks through that flow
and see how you'll be able to make a
call as a quick start so we do a quick
search we see the second link beautiful
is the cloud vision API so if you
haven't seen it yet you know the cloud
vision is you sent us to a service an
image we analyzed it and we returned to
you back a response with what is in that
picture right an analysis with labels
with scoring and all of the above and in
fact if you scroll a little bit on that
landing page you notice there's a try
the API I highly encourage you to try it
out if you haven't done yet
so we can just drag and drop a photo I
think we have one ready even perfect and
it's a cat drag and drop it just to show
you the kind of information we'll get
back it's able to pick up as a cat 99%
accuracy you know or scoring it's a
mammal vertebra so get all these labels
back directly thanks to the API
returning you this information and by
the way you'll notice a bunch of extra
data like web properties you can see a
color gradient also it can give you back
and finally you also have JSON response
if you wanted to parse the JSON great
but you're a developer so you want to be
able to call this programmatically so
we're going to go and click on the view
documentation to go a little bit more
and what we have here so this is a very
standard documentation we explain to you
stuff but one thing I'm gonna bring to
your attention is that in the API is in
reference section there is a client
libraries place or item rather if you
click on that that will open the client
library station this is what I'm saying
we're adding more and more of these
across all of cloud api's and the whole
point is to show you how to get started
so how to install library how to set up
off and then how to make an API call so
just for fun we'll try it in nodejs
see what happens any node developers in
the room by the way yeah okay get sim
perfect so we'll just open you know will
copy the installation open the terminal
and then a window right play
yes we are perfect we'll just npm
install
while this is installing we'll go back
to the actual documentation and just
copy the code scuse me at the bottom
yeah perfect
and then open sublime we'll just use
sublime for this case and create a new
file that we'll call it yeah there's nsj
so just to walk you through really
quickly on what's happening here
so we basically import the module but
then we have to set a project ID our
project ID is called next and friend but
the moment you've created you know
initially you log on to GCP and you're
in that console UI you create a project
the first thing you put the ID here you
instantiate the client then you specify
a local resource in this case so what is
the file we want to analyze the image
and then you call the tech labels that's
it now in our case we don't have wake up
cats so if you open the where we have
actually on the resources we call it
picture just two and then you'll notice
that it's actually the Eiffel Tower so
we're going to ask the vision API to
figure out what the heck this is so back
to the terminal
we'll just run a basically the terminal
actually oh sorry
she's there that means you can tell and
then node passing vision loudly what
back is a bunch of labels which is
perfect power landmarks monuments
everything you would expect from this
right the thing is we know this is the
Eiffel Tower so how come we don't get
the Eiffel Tower because we ask for
labels we didn't ask for a landmark so
just as a heads-up if you go back to the
cloud documentation there's always these
how-to guys that we have and these are
meant to show you how to do something
and given that this is an API the whole
point is to show you how to different
calls on the AP is and how to make use
of the API so if we click here on
detecting landmarks you'll notice that
we want to show you in our seven
languages right all of the samples and
all of the examples per language if
there's a language missing or two
missing it's just because it's coming
we're working hard at adding all of that
but again to make you productive so in
this case no GS is selected you look at
the example it's pretty much the same as
the QuickStart we saw earlier only
difference is at the bottom we're
calling detecting landmarks great as
simple as that we can copy this go back
to the code update the call and then oh
yeah perfect and if we execute it you'll
notice that it will well let's not
predict the future there we go
I figured out that it was the Eiffel
Tower notice that there was no scoring
on this because this is a non verbals
version but if you wanted to make it
more verbose you can have and pass a
bunch of options and for that one last
quick thing if we go back to the client
libraries page at the bottom there's
always an additional resources that
we're adding socially you know you have
links over there to basically the API
reference documentation you have links
to the source code you want to ask a
question on Stack Overflow and just to
let you know within the client library
reference to the API reference we're
adding a lot of examples also in there
just to make sure that as you're
learning about the API look in different
methods we also have an example right
there to help you to make it simple and
lastly everything is on github so just
as an FYI is because the Google cloud
platform organization we have all the DS
repos Google cloud nodes Google Cloud
Ruby in all seven languages now if
you're wondering is that I how come we
talked about seven languages earlier
with the cloud shell we're talking about
not seven languages with the client
libraries is that a coincidence well
actually it's not there is a cloud GCP
wide effort of you know bringing you
forth you said the languages as
first-class citizens we want to make
sure that as a developer when you come
to GCP and you want to put on your I you
know my
my language lens and be able to look at
GCP from that you know from that lens we
have the dock the documentation for you
and the tools for you and things to get
you started so if you actually go to
cloud or google.com for slash Docs at
the very very top you know you'll notice
that there's a bunch of languages these
are the languages that we support in
fact if you click on Java for instance
you'll see that this is a landing page
for Java we have quickstarts we have
tutorials we have code samples all of
that with the ID like your Java
developer you want to learn about this
in a java reality with a java lens right
we got you covered
so you can learn about App Engine flex
App Engine standard all of that using
Java in this case if you click on tools
we also have a bunch of tools for you as
a Java developer remember how in the
console UI we use a debugger we used
ultimately the cloud source repositories
all these tools that we had for you well
if you're a Java developer you probably
use an IDE right so IntelliJ or eclipse
so we kind of need to have all of these
tools directly in your IDE so you don't
have to move away from your IDE and save
environment and work from there so in
the last part of the demo we'll actually
show you that
so we've already pre-installed the
IntelliJ plugin and IntelliJ itself and
if you open here we already have a
proper they've created so just a heads
up if you were to go to the App Engine
flex documentation there is a QuickStart
there as well that has a code sample so
we basically just get clone the repo
which is called getting started Java and
you notice there's also some code there
so if you wanted to look into this a bit
more I encourage you to go and do the
App Engine flex Java QuickStart but all
we did is that we install IntelliJ we
installed the plug-in we get clone to
repo so now we're ready to go and we
have that open right here if you look
it's very simple all we do again is the
hello world we do a do get right we
handle the get request so we want to
show you some of the tools we have in
IntelliJ but before doing that just make
sure that Java developers know we have
some love for them as well it's also as
easy to get started with the client
libraries so in this case we'll just use
a translation API translation API
another one of our machine learning API
is if you go to the client libraries
page now that you know about it you see
that we have in this case or maven
dependency so we can hop back to the
getting started
open the palm file and then just add
this as a dependency great this is done
now we can copy paste also the code so
just to explain what the code does
ultimately it essentially is a client
right defines of text we want to
translate from one language to another
and therefore after that we simply have
a source language and the target
language so in this case we just copy
pasted the imports and then we'll copy
paste this part lovely and then you see
here we translate from English to
Russian we'll probably just you know try
French just Eiffel Tower moments and
then we can just yeah perfect and yeah
obviously we're now printing this to the
console but since we want to return this
to the browser will just update where we
returned back and good concatenation
cool so by the way we also installed the
jetty plugin so as a web server you
might use something else Tomcat for
example but this case jetty works well
if we run this this will basically do a
local testing of the web app and then
we'll just show you how quickly and how
easy it is while jetty is loading this
great
and if you do a quick zoom for those who
know French hello world is bull golden
moment we got it that simple that quick
that easy cool and the last piece really
here just to make it clear is that we
talked about doing all these workflows
in the cloud UI you can access a like do
get push to cloud folks repositories as
a remote repo do debugging deploy to App
Engine well because we install the cloud
tools for IntelliJ plug-in if you click
on tools you'll notice that we have the
Google cloud tools menu or entry here
and you can do exactly what we did
earlier you can setup the cloud post
repo there you can attach your debugger
and do live debug you can deploy to App
Engine standard and App Engine flex in
fact if you click on deploy to App
Engine you'll notice that you know you
can select your project ID you can set
some information about your application
that's like we did earlier and push it
up to App Engine and have it run in and
scale up and scale out great so yeah
that was that part we can switch back to
the slides
lovely so again the whole point here is
that we want to make a developer
experience easier so you want to use
note you want to use go net we want to
give you client libraries that are easy
use well-documented we look at vision
with nodejs
we look at the translation API with Java
this cloud tools and tell for IntelliJ
but we have that for eclipse we have
that for visual studio again all with
the idea to meeting you where you are as
a developer and you want to learn more
about each of these languages I
recommend going to one of these language
documentation mentation set and learn
about the tool that we have for you and
we'll keep adding them making them
better with the developer in line great
we can jump into the wrap-up so this is
everything we cover cloud shell cloud
SDK cloud client libraries and if you
want to dig deeper in more of these I
suggest looking at these talks so some
of them already happened yesterday some
of them are happening I believe this
afternoon and some more Ruby I think is
right after this if you want to learn
more about how we're supporting your
language in GCP d socks is something
that you want to look at and also the
videos will be online so when we look
into that and finally as next steps sign
up if you're interested in cloud shell
you can do
cloud shell Pro sign up at this bitly
link learn about it let us know what you
think we want to make sure that you know
we hear you download the latest cloud
SDK just like Eileen was saying to try
out the Alpha features and play with
that and you can send feedback at
g-cloud feedback g-class sends you back
and then try out a client libraries for
everything we talked today you can go to
this link which is a github repo next -
diving team under my username just to
see all the stuff we talked about links
and the forum for cloud shell pro so
everything will be in one place so you
can refer back to this if you have
questions for me you can also just file
an issue I'll be happy to answer and
that was it that's it cool
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]